Amen. Well, that was our kids camp this week.
If you would celebrate what God did with us, he changed lives,
he affected hearts and uh, really did a big work.
Thank you for praying for that.
If you'd celebrate with me about what God's done, please, he is good to us.
It's great to be together this morning.
I did hear a rumor that there's no coffee out there. I don't drink it at all,
but uh, let me just warn you, we're still gonna be okay, right?
It's gonna be okay. We're gonna worship, we're still gonna see God move.
It's okay. Uh, we'll be surviving that. My name's John.
I'm one of the pastors here. Uh, it's great to be together.
I'm grateful for the opportunity to open God's word with you.
I was blessed to spend my first two weeks post sabbatical, uh,
at our student camp the week before and then, uh,
leading fourth grade boys this week at Kids camp. And it was a sweet time. Uh,
you just saw it, it was awesome. Uh,
I encourage you to go next year if you haven't been as a leader, uh,
send your kids as well. It's powerful.
But all that makes it a bit ironic that I'm preaching about rest this morning,
uh, because I felt a few times like buddy the elf, when he is asked,
how'd you sleep? He's like, great. I got a full 40 minutes. Right?
So that's what I felt a couple times.
It's actually part of my main point today though, when you think about rest,
here's the reality I've learned recently. It,
it's possible to rest physically without resting spiritually.
It's possible to rest physically but not rest spiritually.
Like you can take two weeks off, you could take three months off.
You could take a year off, you could even retire.
But if your heart is not resting in the Lord,
if you are not finding your rest in Jesus,
you'll still be at that red line pace internally.
And whatever physical rest you get is really worthless in the end.
So here's the core truth today.
The truth is that true rest is spiritual first and physical second.
True rest is,
is spiritual first and physical second,
we must place a priority on internal rest,
on spiritual rest.
But understanding that is actually then how our physical rest begins to
actually work. And we'll see that today.
But as we get there,
first I wanna share a little bit about my experience with rest.
Recently as I went on my sabbatical and just been back two weeks,
getting us all on the same page of really what a sabbatical even is and then
really what rest is as I talk about what I faced
in that season.
And so the concept of the sabbatical actually goes back to the Old Testament
biblical practice of a Sabbath year for the farmland.
It's the idea of a year of release that's in the word itself.
Meaning every seven years they were to give the land that they farmed a year
off, work it for six and then take one year off.
And this was to let the soil replenish its nutrients to
replenish what it needed to come back even more fruitful for the next six
years of planting and harvesting. And they would see,
it's amazing to watch how it would work out that way that the six years would
produce more than they could in seven with the same land.
And so it's been used as a,
a way of treating academics and medical professionals and some things to
eliminate burnout. Over the years, we've applied that in the similar way.
And so we've done the same thing here. Uh, before we moved here in 2018.
The elders put in our policies a three month sabbatical every five years for
my position. And it means that, uh,
we want long-term ministry from our people on staff.
And so this helps ensure that. So it's not punitive, it's not mandated,
it's not anything that we have to do. It's meant to care for me. And,
and also now for our other staff members that we have implemented shorter
versions of it for the same timeframe.
I needed a break. That's what I, I faced after a long stretch of ministry,
even before coming here, needed a break.
And my family needed me to reinvest in them because they serve in a lot more
hidden way. Uh, they,
they share me with the church and so they serve that way so that
they needed some time with me as well.
And so about a year ago began thinking through what this would look like for me
to take my first sabbatical ever. And so I knew it was to prioritize my family.
That was key number one. But I wanted to ensure that it was a good,
healthy process for me to go away and,
and do some things that would really be helpful.
And so I talked to my counselor, I've been meeting with for a couple years,
talked to others who'd had sabbaticals as well. Like, what did you experience?
How did you face this? What was I gonna face when I go into it?
And so I was prepared for what I was gonna face emotionally and,
and spiritually.
I knew what was coming when I was gonna feel these sorts of things that,
that I wouldn't have this affirmation loop every Sunday.
I wouldn't have social media to where I could post something,
get a lot of likes from all that I knew I was gonna have to face that.
And I also knew that I wasn't gonna have to face the enemy attacking my
identity, that he was going to tell me that I was,
that I was worthless 'cause I'm not producing anything right now
that no one cared about me. He was gonna toss that stuff in my mind.
And so I knew that was coming and I pre-decided how to handle that.
But what I was not prepared for
was the physical side of what I was about to face.
See, I've been going hard for 13 straight years in ministry.
And there is a roller coaster of leadership challenges through that season of
time. C o v was in the middle of that.
I I counted back preaching, uh,
200 plus unique sermons.
Then you're thinking of,
of moves between states and transitions between churches,
vertigo a couple years ago.
And
You're adding all of that together.
Plus you add in this subtle achievement drive
that creeps into even churches where it's all about bigger
and better and more and growth and success in other people's eyes.
You add all that together.
And it turns out I was way more tired than I thought I was.
Like, if you would've asked me back in April, right before like Easter Sunday,
April, if you'd have asked me, I would've said, I feel fine. I feel great. I've,
I'm ready to go. I'm ready for the next season of life.
I don't need to take a sabbatical.
But April 16th, I preached on Sunday and I stepped away on Monday,
shut everything off.
And what that means also is that that faucet of adrenaline shut off.
And my brain kind of freaked out a little bit. Physically.
I felt like I was in a fog for about three or four weeks.
Like my brain wasn't, I couldn't remember people's names.
Like we had staff members come by the house on a scavenger hunt.
I was out mowing. I was like, I can't remember your name. Like, it was weird.
I didn't tell 'em that. But I didn't in the moment, couldn't,
couldn't think of it. I just couldn't conceive.
It was a physical reaction physically ill for about a week or two,
I was apathetic, just kind of generally.
This malaise was all over my body. So I didn't know what happened.
So I was like researching this. I'm like, what's going on?
Talking to my counselor, what is happening?
And I discovered that essentially my brain had been addicted to adrenaline.
You've heard the term adrenaline junkies.
It's literally an addiction that that adrenaline,
the dopamine hit comes and it causes you to need it and run
on it. Now let me, let me say this.
Adrenaline is a good thing created by God that when you get in a crisis
moment, you have some kind of almost supernatural, but,
but over the top physical abilities.
That's what you need to protect yourself at times when something happens, right?
But you were never meant to run on it all the time
to run at this red line pace, this high octane pace.
That's never what adrenaline was meant for.
And so what I was feeling for those first couple weeks was a physical
withdrawal from the drug of adrenaline.
Well, finally, thankfully, after that first month,
my brain cleared up. I was able to think normally things slowed down,
felt slower, my blood pressure lowered. I was able to sleep normally.
Like it all started to hit reset a little bit after three or four weeks.
And the rest of our time together, even those couple weeks were sweet.
But the rest of our time, those two months were incredibly sweet as a family.
Uh, we got to do a ton of things together. Memories made time at home together,
games, family camp, Levi's 10 trip.
We did all of that in this stretch of season of time. And, and so again,
like I said last week,
thank you for that time that you care for us so well towards that.
Our family is better off because of it. Now we're grateful.
But I share about that first month because what that month did is it set me back
spiritually. It,
it put me behind what I thought I was going to experience.
I had all these big plans, like for my sabbatical, getting away with Jesus,
spending days outside, just resting and praying. Like I had this,
this whole plan, this whole idea of wow, this would look,
but I really didn't wanna do much of anything. I mean,
the understanding of that struggle of just the day-to-day of like choosing to
walk into God's word and be with him. I just didn't really want to do it.
Like it felt like a wilderness season for me.
So that was hard. It set me behind. But here's how the Lord redeemed that again,
we know the Lord takes everything and turns it for good.
But this is so he did see for the first time in a long time,
I felt hungry and thirsty spiritually.
Here's one of the things that you, you may not understand.
If you've never worked on a church staff before in a Christian setting,
you might say, working at a church,
we're always kind of snacking on God's word. We're always around it.
Like we're, we're talking about it, we're studying for teachings. We're,
we're talking about it in Bible studies and we're having having meetings about
like we're, we're always kind of around it.
And so like you're having this bag of Cheetos at home all the time,
just kind of snacking all the time. You never get hungry.
But this was like I was fasting for a season.
Like I stepped away from that and I fasted.
And it reminded me that I need to take my hunger and thirst to Jesus
alone.
Not just to being around Christians and around the Bible enough and even
teaching it. But, but I'm hungry. I'm thirsty.
And so I need to take it to him.
Now I want you to think about all of this for a second. I mean, just,
just think about what I had the opportunity to do. This is, this is a blessing.
I know not everybody gets this so I don't take it for granted. But,
but think about this. I didn't have to work for three months and I got paid.
I was able to travel the world and see our,
our missionaries and see the pastors in Wales.
I was able to experience some really cool things that way.
I got to focus on my family in deep ways,
just be with them 24 7 for a couple months.
As sweet as those things are though,
as much as we're all sitting here like, yeah, I'd love to do that.
As as sweet as those things are though, if I'm not resting spiritually,
then they will not truly fill my cup.
Again, you can rest physically without resting spiritually,
but you can take three months off and you come back more exhausted
if you're not resting spiritually.
That's why the theme of my sabbatical ended up being this quote from
Augustine, a man who back in the fourth century,
he understood what it's like to pursue dopamine hits.
He tried all kinds of things kinda like Solomon did in the Old Testament.
He was trying all this stuff looking for the next high in his mind.
And his prayer ended up being this God,
you have made us for yourself and our heart is
restless until it finds its rest in you.
Like God, you've made us for yourself. You've made us to be with you.
And our heart is restless until it finds its rest in you
alone.
Was I searching for all the things like Solomon was like Augustine was? No,
but I was not finding my rest purely in Jesus.
So that's what I hope to show you today from Hebrews four,
the reality that Jesus is our true rest.
He's our spiritual rest that is infinitely better than any physical rest that we
can pursue.
And so I take your copy of God's word and turn to Hebrews four with me.
That's what I wanna do is start with reading this passage in Hebrews four
verses one through 13. It might be a bit confusing as we read it,
but ultimately it'll show us what true rest is and where we find it,
not just in taking some time off.
So Hebrews four verses one through 13.
Therefore, while the promise of entering his rest still stands,
let us fear list any of you should seem to have failed to reach it
for good news came to us just as to them.
But the message they heard,
he's talking about Israel in the past did not benefit them because they were not
united by faith with those who listened
For we who have believed. Enter that rest. As God has said,
as I swore in my wrath, they shall not enter my rest.
Although his works were finished from the foundation of the world,
for he has somewhere spoken of the seventh day in this way.
And God rested on the seventh day from all his works.
And again in this passage he said, they shall not enter my rest
since therefore it remains for some to enter it.
And those who formally received the good news failed to enter because of
disobedience. Again,
he appoints a certain day today saying through David so long afterward,
in the words already quoted today, if you hear his voice,
do not harden your hearts. He quoted that back in chapter three
for if Joshua had given them rest,
God would not have spoken of another day later on.
So then there remains a Sabbath rest for the people of God,
for whoever has entered God's rest,
has also rested from his works as God did from his.
Let us therefore strive to enter that rest so that no one may fall by.
The same sort of disobedience for the word of God is living inactive,
sharper than any two-edged sword,
piercing to the division of soul and of spirit of joints, of marrow,
discerning the thoughts and intentions of the heart.
And no creatures hidden from its sight,
but all are naked and exposed to the eyes of him to whom we must give
account.
So I started by sharing my experience with rest.
But now I wanna show you a couple other perspectives on rest that we can find
here in this passage.
First God's experience with rest.
Let's look at God's experience. Now. We don't often think of God resting,
do we?
But
That's right here. We saw it in verses three and four.
And this is a reference back to Genesis two,
where God rested on the seventh day from all his works, his work of creation,
everything he created on the seventh day, he rested. But but what do we,
what do we think when we hear that it,
it seems like God rested from all his works,
that he kind of just wound the clock and then left it and stopped working
altogether. But that's not true, right?
Because we know God continues to work today. He's still at work.
And so that's not true.
It wasn't true that God was exhausted and had to quit working and he just did
too much in six days. No, what he was modeling here for us was a rhythm,
a template for us to follow six days of work and then a day of rest.
It's a template that we'll show see throughout God's word.
But then it also means if we see this about God,
that there's more to it than just physical rest. 'cause God didn't need to.
So he's setting a template here. And then even here in Hebrews four,
he's talking about seeking rest in a way that's both today
and ongoing.
So it can't just be about physical rest here.
There's something else happening deeper,
which is why Hebrews four then uses Israel's experience on rest
to instruct us more on what true rest really is.
Saw God's experience.
Now we see Israel's experience as a helpful directive for us today.
Now, I read chapter four here,
part of it that actually extends up into chapter three in Hebrews,
where the author directly quote Psalm 95 and Psalm
95 is where God shares about the exodus where he delivered his people out of
Egypt and slavery. And the gist of all of it, all of chapter three,
even here in chapter four,
is that those who were redeemed from slavery in Egypt,
they had every opportunity to enter into rest in the Promised
Land.
But they refused to worship and obey God alone.
God had it for 'em, but they refused. They rebelled against God.
How'd they rebel? They turned against Moses, right?
They had this leader named Moses that God had appointed and they turned against
him and rebelled against God.
They didn't believe God's promises were better than the sin that they wanted.
They didn't believe. So they disobeyed.
That's why that first generation,
the ones who were redeemed out of slavery needed,
saw all the miracles That first generation wandered in the desert for 40 years.
And that first generation was not allowed into the Promised land
Because they chose these other things instead of believing God.
And so Moses, that was their experience with him. But then there was also,
we see in verse eight here in Hebrews four,
this man named Joshua just kinda randomly throws him in there. But,
but re, the reason Joshua's in here is because Joshua was Moses' successor.
And Joshua in fact was,
was one of the few original first generation out of Egypt
Israelites, who did believe in God, who did believe God's promise.
And so he was one of the few handful that did get to go in to the promised land.
In fact, Joshua got to lead them in the second generation.
God used Joshua to lead them into the promised land.
But notice did you see in verse eight
for if Joshua had given them rest,
God would not have spoken of another day later on. And so notice,
even though they were in the promised land at this point,
they still didn't have true rest.
They're even in the land that that day, if rest is still coming in the future,
Hebrews four says,
'cause remember once they went into the land,
they still just kind of bounced around fighting battles against these other
nations. Even when they kind of settled down a little bit,
their hearts were still bouncing around following all these other gods.
So again, if we're talking true spiritual rest,
Moses didn't, Joshua didn't,
the Israelites did not experience this rest.
There was still a different day coming,
a better leader coming.
Well we already had the spoiler as we read through chapter four, right?
It's Jesus, we know that Moses couldn't, Joshua couldn't.
But Jesus is the better. Moses is the better. Joshua,
this is the one who can give true rest.
Jesus was and is the day later on that Hebrews four talks about where true rest
would come.
Jesus is the God man who would say this in Matthew chapter 11
verses 28 through 30. Jesus said,
come to me all who labor and are heavy laden. And I will give you rest.
Take my yoke upon you.
Learn from me for I'm gentle and lowly and heart and you will find rest.
Check this out for your souls.
For my yoke is easy. My burden is light.
So Jesus is offering rest for our souls here.
They get rest in the promised land. They get in the land. But no, no, they,
they didn't have rest for their souls. Jesus is saying,
here's what rest actually is. It's for your soul.
That's the good news that Hebrews four,
two was referring to when Jesus would live and die and resurrect in our place
to give us soul rest that they had to look
forward to. It's what we enter by faith.
It's what Israel could not enter due to a lack of faith.
They couldn't trust God, didn't believe God. And so they didn't have rest.
They didn't see God's promises as good. They chose other ways.
This is what Jesus offers.
The question I was thinking of as I was writing that is,
is that something that you have done
to be like Israel turning away from the true rest belief in God? Faith?
Have you, have you turned to all these other rest stops
instead of Jesus, instead of faith in God and his promises?
Maybe that's you, but you have done,
maybe that's what you're doing right now and you're seeking rest in all these
other things. Remember, your heart is restless until it finds its rest in him.
It's why you're exhausted. It's why you're tired. It's why you're frustrated.
'cause you're seeking rest everywhere else instead of what it was designed for.
See the fact that three times in Hebrews three and four, it quotes Psalm 95,
this today verse right today, don't harden your hearts, it brings it forward.
It means it matters for us today just as much as it did back then.
'cause Hebrews four, nine says,
there remains a Sabbath rest for the people of God.
So we've got to be honest with ourselves and look at our experience of whether
we truly trust in the Lord and rest in the Lord or not.
This has to be something we consider. Every one of us in our own lives are,
are we like Israel?
I mean at times we all are,
but but what in my life looks like Israel refusing to believe God's promises
are better than anything that I, I can find here how much of my day, my life,
my thought process, my actions shows I,
I don't really want what God promises. I want what all this other stuff has.
Like let's be honest with ourselves about that.
Where am I searching out what I'm only meant to find in Jesus?
That's why Hebrews four verses 11 through 13 point us to one way we can seek
this rest in Jesus. It says,
let us therefore strive to enter that rest so that no one may fall for this.
By the same sort of disobedience,
the word of God is living and active sharpening two-edged sword,
piercing to the very core of who we are,
discerning the thoughts and intentions of our hearts.
And no creatures hidden from his sight but all are naked and exposed to the eyes
of him to whom we must give an account.
And so unlike Israel and the wilderness, remember they,
they heard the words of God, the promises of God.
And they refused to believe them, refused to obey them. For us,
we are to rest in God's word.
We're to rest in scripture so we don't fall away like they did.
Like we've been given God's word too.
Are we going to deny it and disbelieve it and say,
forget that we have our own plan or are we gonna follow him?
But if you see the first few words of verse 11, it says,
strive to enter that rest. When we talk about rest,
it doesn't mean lazily sitting on a couch somewhere
In God's word.
Rest means striving in God's power for God's
purposes. Paul said that in one of his letters. So he's,
he's working with all the energy that God works within him. Again,
he's working harder than everybody else but not because he has to because God is
working through him. It's what James one even reminds us.
It says be doers of the word.
Not hearers only deceiving yourselves.
If anyone's a hearer of the word and not a doer,
he's like a man who looks intently at his natural face in a mirror.
He looks at himself, goes away once forgets what he was like.
But the one who looks into the perfect law,
that's God's law of liberty and perseveres being no hearer who
forgets, but a doer who acts. He will be blessed in his doing.
Right? So Israel in the wilderness heard God's word.
They refused to let the scalpel of God's word cut away things
that were not of him.
Will we,
will we refuse to let God's word cut what needs to be cut?
Will we refuse to obey God's word and will we,
will we stop striving to enter his rest? 'cause again,
blessed in all his doing. What is that talking about?
That's talking about the way life works.
It's good to obey God 'cause he designed it a certain way
because if he says in Hebrews four, strive to enter that rest,
doesn't that sound like works?
And James one says you need to be obedient doers of the word.
Doesn't that sound like, man, we're gonna be working a lot more.
I thought God rested from his works.
I I thought we don't have to do anything anymore 'cause God did it all for us.
No, that's what this is saying.
The the deliverance of God brings about
obedience.
The trust we have in God's plan is what brings about
striving. 'cause again, like I just said,
God designed life to work one way. When we walk his pathway,
that's restful. When we walk a different path, what happens?
Carnage, chaos. Life is harder.
Now it doesn't mean life is perfect,
but it sure means things work a lot better when we do it God's way.
And so we rest in his word.
But that's the other way. We strive to enter God's rest.
We have to do that by faith.
We rest in him by faith,
trusting his word in faith.
Now first that's an eternal rest.
Faith is, is what gives us eternal rest.
Now here's, here's a little glimpse into biblical theology.
This is like studying the whole Bible as one.
We can trace the entire storyline of God's word from the
garden of Eden in Genesis one all the way to the very end in Revelation
21 and 22, the garden of the new creation.
And you think about Adam and Eve in the original garden before sin,
they had perfect rest, perfect fellowship with God,
perfect fellowship with each other and with creation,
God is one day going to redeem all of that and give us perfect rest again
in him relationship with him, relationship with each other,
relation with creation. All that's coming back.
It's like page one and page whatever one is on the end of your Bible.
It's all of that, right?
So that's the storyline of God's redemptive
history.
It's rest at the beginning and it's rest at the end.
This is an eternal rest.
That's why above all else,
when you hear God's voice today,
don't harden your heart like Israel did in the wilderness.
They
Didn't believe.
When you hear God's voice when he's speaking to you today,
not me, when he's speaking to you today, don't harden your heart.
Turn from your sin. Turn from yourself and trust in Jesus' life,
death and resurrection in your place.
When you hear that, that's the hope eternally.
That's what gives you rest eternally. Don't harden your heart to it. You,
you can get the rest he's offering and just think about what that rest
means for a second. That means you have no fear of death anymore.
No fear of eternity. No fear of being separated from God ever again.
That's restful, isn't it?
And and again, it's restful.
Not because you were able to work your way out of it somehow,
it's because Jesus has done it all for you. That's rest.
So there's eternal rest in Jesus that's absolutely critically the most important
part of all of this.
But there's also some practical applications as we go through our lives about
how this rest plays out. And it starts even weekly.
There's
A weekly rest rests.
'cause remember on the seventh day God rested from his works.
He didn't need to but he did. He stopped what he was doing.
It shows up again in the fourth of the 10 Commandments, Sabbath.
Jesus blessed it in Mark two. He says it's given to humans as a break from work.
Six days, one off right? Add it all up.
You trace that all throughout scripture.
It reminds us that we were never meant to work 24 7.
We're never designed to work 24 7.
And so God wants us to trust him by faith
that he will provide for us in six days what we think we can produce in seven.
That was agricultural back then, right? They, they worked six days,
let it rest on the seventh day they get back to it.
They always had more than if they refused and worked on the seventh.
Listen, that's one place I got off track.
Why was that adrenaline faucet running so hard? It's because I had no limits.
I thought I had to and, and this was, I would never have said this out loud,
but I, I kind of internally thought I had to keep this kingdom thing going.
Like I had, I gotta advance the kingdom myself in my own power.
And so I could never shut it off. I always gotta answer one more email.
I gotta gotta study one more thing. I gotta respond one more thing on social.
I have to do all of these things. But this
Reminds us that part of rest,
part of rest involves trusting the Lord for his provision and for
his results in my life.
It's been said this way, our heavenly Father never gives us too much to do.
People will and we assign ourselves an overload,
but never the Lord.
He knows what he wants from each of us.
And there's plenty of time in his day for things essential to his plan.
We do him a grave injustice when we fall into the habit of compulsive
overwork.
Even Jesus stepped away at times, didn't he?
He could have constantly gone.
He could have been in the crowd and seen the fame. Even his disciples were like,
Hey Jesus, let's go over here. Let's, let's leverage your fame.
These people want know these crowds over here. And Jesus is like, nah,
actually we're going this way 'cause there's one person over here I need to talk
to or I'm, I'm gonna go up on the mountain by myself for a while.
Like Jesus himself pulled away.
Yet I somehow think I'm indispensable.
Like we need to remember
God is doing just fine without us.
And
Maybe I'm just talking to myself here that God's doing just fine without me.
He doesn't need me yet.
I think somehow I've got to keep this thing going.
But that comes back to the final practical application of Jesus being our rest.
It shows up daily. Yeah, we got this weekly rhythm,
but every day,
every moment God shows up as our rest daily.
See, just like God rested from his labors,
just like he gave Israel rest in the promised land,
he promised it.
He provided this one day per week rest for his people.
Hebrews four,
nine says that there remains a Sabbath rest for the people of God.
It's still there. And,
and so that remember is not just a physical rest
Where we take time off from work. It's a true spiritual rest.
It's what verse 10 continues.
For whoever has entered God's rest has also rested from his works as God
did from his. This is what I mean by a daily rest. This is a,
a soul rest where you and I daily find the comfort in
the fact that we don't have to try and earn our salvation anymore.
Like we don't have to try to keep track and and balance the scales and make sure
we're gonna be good before God. Because later in Jesus,
we find that he offers complete rest from the labor of our self
effort
Because
His work counts for ours.
Hebrews 10 12 later says,
he offered one sacrifice for sins forever and then sat
down at the right hand of God.
It's kind of going back to God in creation, right? He rests on the seventh day.
Jesus did the work and then he rested.
He had completed,
he ceased from the labor of atonement because there was nothing more to be
done ever. He offered for sacrifice for sins,
one sacrifice.
And it was good for everyone every time,
every historical era. It was good enough, it was enough.
And so he sat down and rested. That's how we rest.
Because when we remember that,
that means we don't have to achieve God's favor anymore.
We don't have to try to earn God's favor anymore. It is given to us.
You don't have to try to,
to work your knuckles to the bone to try to be good enough to be religious
enough. You don't have to do that anymore because Jesus gives it to you.
Is that not freeing? Listen, if that's your identity,
if you are a child of God by faith, resting in Christ,
his work counts for yours. That's rest.
That's how we can stand here and we can just say to Jesus,
singing as loud as we can with our arms wide open saying, Jesus, I'm yours.
You are my firm foundation. I can't do anything.
And we're proud of that in some ways, right? I can't do anything. God,
you've got it all. You did it all. Praise God. That's rest.
If you're sitting there and you're trying to debate with yourself whether you're
good enough, that's not restful. I mean, I hope I did enough this week.
Hope I wasn't too bad 10 years ago. That's not a soul rest, is it?
This, this is what we're talking about.
Rest in Jesus and think about what that allows you to do. Now,
if that's where you land, if that's your confidence,
you don't have to listen to the accusations of the enemy anymore
'cause they're covered, right? Jesus knew you were gonna do it.
Jesus covered it with his blood. So the enemy tosses it back in your face.
You say, yeah, I know, but Jesus paid for it.
It's covered, it's gone. It's done. When you're resting in Jesus daily,
you don't listen to the enemy. You're free also to obey Jesus.
Even if it costs you a lot,
You're free to give generously because you know you have it all in the end. And
what is this stuff?
Just give it away because Jesus is all I have and I've got him forever.
You're free to go on mission because what can man do to you and kill you? Okay?
I get to be with Jesus. They make fun of you.
Like I don't care what you think Jesus approves to me.
You're free to not be on social media because it's really just a big
self-promotion platform anyway. Why do I need you to impress you?
I could just be secure resting in Jesus.
We can stop trying to blend worldly ambition with the mission of the church and
we can just let God be God. And our job is just to be faithful.
We just be obedient and let God take care of the results.
You can humbly sleep. If you're resting daily,
you can humbly sleep like the farmer in the mark four parable that Jesus talked
about who scattered the seed. He goes to bed, he wakes up,
and somehow that thing sprouted how?
Because God causes the growth.
And so when you've scattered the seed in your life,
whether that's spiritual or even in your workplace, whatever it is,
and you've set that out and you just say, God, okay, this is your deal.
You can humbly sleep in that. Do you remember what Psalm 1 27 said last week?
Unless the Lord builds the house, those who build it labor in vain,
unless the Lord watches over the city, the watchman stays awake in vain.
It is in vain that you rise up early and go late to rest.
Eating the bread of anxious toil for he gives to his beloved
sleep.
You can rest because God never does.
You
Can You can rest because God's the one who causes the growth.
You can rest because God's the one who provides, who protects.
You don't have to try to keep yourself safe. God protects his people
again by faith, by trusting his word, his promises,
by believing that our good God is better than anything else this world
can offer. He is our true rest.
He is where true life is found. And so give him your sin today.
Give him your shame. Give him your past.
Give him your future.
Give him your life because his ways are better.
That's rest.